beaune sous le choc l'annnonce de la
garde à vue d'un insuline aurait ébranlé
la ville le maire depuis 23 ans de la
commune est entendu dans le cadre d'une
information judiciaire ouverte contre x
depuis plus d'un an pour des chefs de
détournements de fonds publics recel et
blanchiment
cet après-midi le sujet était sur toutes
les lèvres dans les rues de la ville je
suis étonné je suis surpris parce que
c'est un métier tu es moi pour moi
moi je rencontre et de temps en temps
j'aurais j'aurais jamais cru ça mais bon
que celui que je vous dise maintenant
c'est tout on en apprend tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
loups j'ai travaillé même sous ses
ordres
monsieur c'est que nous c'est pour ça
cette raison là je suis un peu surpris
quand même mais vu la conjoncture qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle on est on est
surpris de plus rien des membres de sa
famille ont aussi été placés en garde à
vue selon une source proche de l'enquêté
mais le procureur n'a pas confirmé cette
information s'en tenant à un court
communiqué côté politique pas de
réaction hormis celle du conseiller
d'opposition raphaël billé moi je
regrette sincèrement que par ce genre de
d'éventuels comportements encore une
fois je mets bien au conditionnel on
rajoute une nouvelle fois à l'image
dégradée des politiques on nous renvoie
vers un ancien monde politique qui
visiblement à différents étages a été
capable de malversations financières
c'est derrière ces murs qu'alain
suguenot et trois personnes de son
entourage sont entendus depuis ce matin
dans les locaux de la section économique
et financière de la police judiciaire de
dijon sur commission rogatoire du juge
d'instruction une garde à vue qui peut
durer jusqu'à demain matin et être
éventuellement prolongée de 24 heures
par le magistrat